will give everyone a moment to uh
shuffle in and i'll try to catch names
as they fly across the screen some names
are new to me some names i have seen
before
i see evan i see alexa hi everybody
uh let's see oh clifford you're here
again good to see you oh virtually see
you ken and again everyone's name's i
don't say your name because she flew off
dan brian lewis good to see you or
virtually talk to you at least always
fun to have you around i hope you're
doing some good mushroom hunting for
those who don't know brian lewis is our
mushroom aficionado we give a whole talk
of the art conference about using shiny
to identify good mushroom patches it's
really awesome
let's see who else is coming in here as
we go and again if i don't say hi to you
because your name flew by yeah oh paul
poglio good to see you
um all right a bunch of people shuffling
their way in hope everyone's having a
lovely august wherever you may be
and i imagine we have mostly northern
hemisphere people so hope you're
enjoying your summer if we have any
southern hemisphere people hope you're
enjoying your winter
i know sometimes we do get people from
you know below the equator and we get
people across the prime already and also
we get people from all over and of
course this is recorded so people can
watch it anytime they want later at
their leisure
so everyone's already coming on in and
we'll get started in just a few moments
with our announcements
in fact i will pull up our announcements
as soon as i find them
great
so
all right i'll get started just a few
announcements and hopefully by then
everyone will be here to join in on the
talk
okay so again welcome everybody this is
the august meetup in the year two of the
pandemic
just when we thought things were looking
up things might be uh stretching out a
little bit
so those of you who have attended in
person or those of you who have even
been here for the virtual ones no i
always like to start
the meetup by asking who is hiring
unfortunately i can't have everyone
jumping up here and shouting who's
hiring because you know it's just the
webinar platform
so
if you are hiring you want to hire
somebody
go to the ny hacker slack
um i believe um we'll be able to post a
link to get there if you it's
nyhakgar.org
slack.html there's a link there and we
have a channel called job postings
uh there's been a number of postings on
there i know throughout the meetup
throughout the past 10 plus years
a lot of people have gotten jobs through
the meetup so i hope people continue to
get jobs through the meetup i know just
noam ross the one of the sponsor for
today's meetup posted just a few days
ago about a job he's hiring for so if
you're looking to hire you might have
posted for two jobs
if you're looking to hire please go to
job postings and post your job on there
and let's get people from the meetup job
you're gonna find lots of great people
since i have the benefit of actually
being on camera i will tell you that i
am hiring both full-time and part-time
we're looking for someone to do
technical sales an account executive
role but it's good if you know about r
python
you know shinee our studio jupiter stuff
like that it's good to have chemical
chops uh in a sales role
we are hiring a data scientist
we are hiring we're hiring a shiny
developer and a linux assistant so if
four rolls open
only one of those up on our website we
will get more up on landeranalytics.com
careers
in the next few days because we have a
few roles we're hiring for and i will
get them all posted up there
and we'll also post them on the job
postings channel as i encourage everyone
else to do
and i see someone already posted that
worked awesomely thank you b carlson uh
so i just saw the username thank you for
posting
it wouldn't be a new york open
statistical programming meetup without
pizza
so
mine today oh the tip just broke off
so mine today
is from it's not a bite i swear i
wouldn't hold up a bite pizza here's the
tip everybody all right
um mine is from a place called nomad
it's been sitting at my home for just
about 15 minutes so you know the cheese
lock is in there but as a good
neapolitan pie had good cheese like out
of the box
and has some good charring on the bottom
because a good wood burning place should
i hope everyone else has good pizza or
other snacks to keep you full during
this talk
i so miss having pizza of everybody and
having the pizza pool
hopefully soon one day we'll see each
other we could have pizza together and
other things so hope everyone knows good
pizza wherever you may be or again other
snacks if you want to have an inferior
food pizza it's up to you that's cool by
me
so our next meetup we are not quite
ready to announce the speaker yet uh but
it will be september first or second
all right stay tuned for that we'll have
an announcement coming up soon at
meetup.com
we will tweet it we'll put it up on
slack so september 1st and set or second
we're gonna have our next meetup it will
be virtual just like this one i know in
the past we talked about making
september in person
but even before kovitz started getting
worse it was tough to find companies
that were ready to host someone on
september 1st because they were open
they were opening their offices in
september i don't think they're even
doing that anymore so stay tuned for
september 1st announcement
also in september
the new york r conference is back
um we have workshops september 1st the
week before the conference to avoid
conflicts with
labor day and rosh hashanah we're
hosting it on september 1st we have
workshops from we have six workshops i'm
gonna forget some people but we have max
[ __ ] cass akimoto dan chen we have
malcolm barrett and lucy d'agostino and
i'm forgetting lucy's last name you have
your own nansens and i think we have one
more i said we had six i'm forgetting
one i apologize to every person i'm
forgetting we have one more that's
september 1st you can find out more at
rstats.ai
nyr
then the following week september 9th
and 10th we have the new york r
conference this is the seventh year
going strong for a long time
um currently
it is still planned to be both in person
and virtual
though every day we have long
discussions monitoring what's happening
and if we need to make the switch to
virtual we'll let everyone know and
we'll hold it completely virtually
september 9th and 10th 2. we're ready
unlike last year we know what's
happening this year so we are ready to
go if we need to switch over and we're
doing virtual component anyway so stay
tuned and don't worry if you bought an
in-person ticket we'll switch you over
to virtual don't worry about that
um hope a lot of you can attend it's two
of my favorite days of the year to be
honest it's just really great we have
great speakers here some repeats some
new we have you know mainstays like
david robinson max [ __ ] and west
mckinney we have newcomers like osmo
toomey euron janssen's and caitlyn hudon
we have a lot of good people speaking we
have 24 speakers lined up again if you
want to learn more go to rstats.ai
nyr and check out the workshops the
speakers we have a whole agenda up there
it's going to be a lot of fun
if you're buying tickets the code is ny
hack r and i see nicole posted the link
and the promo code to the chat here on
zoom get a 20 discount on any of the
tickets the workshops the conference
tickets using code ny hackar so go check
it i see steven's very excited to attend
i'm excited for this conference i really
do love this conference so much
i'm really excited to be there if your
company's looking to sponsor either two
you know because you have cool open
source stuff you want to show you have
cool products you're looking to hire
contact us get in touch with me get in
touch nicole you can find me on twitter
on anywhere i'm i'm very reachable
through the websites and everything
for more information about the meetup
itself
visit
nyhackr.org
we have
11 years worth of slideshows up there
and probably about eight years worth of
videos there's a lot of good content up
there the site as i said before is
poorly designed so it needs to be
rebuilt but it's all open source and
it's on github so make a pr if you think
it's ugly because i designed it and it
is ugly i admit it's totally ugly
all right since we can't ask questions
of ian directly what we're going to do
is
i'd ask anyone who has a question to p
please post it on slack there is a
channel called monthly meetup chat
go in there post the your question
and i will collate all the questions and
at the end of the talk i will grill in
with the toughest ones you have all
right make it hard try to stump them
let's really go let's go deep on this
one so again that is in slack monthly
meetup chat
i mentioned in passing i just want to
thank ecohealth alliance for supplying
the zoom for us
they've been supplying the zoom link for
us since
the first month of the pandemic
uh and thank you very much particularly
to
noam and emma the two people there
really have our backs at this
organization they've been um helping us
out this whole time so just a little
round of applause for them helping us
out i'll do a little virtual golf clap
to thank them for that
so hope everyone had a fun time remember
next month we have a meetup we have
workshops and the new york r conference
so i am super excited for that and we
will keep you posted what we're doing
based on cdc and new york city
guidelines all right we will keep
everyone posted about that so with that
i am very excited to introduce ian who's
going to give a talk about a package or
a few packages that i am personally very
excited about um
they're really cool and i'm not gonna
talk it up too much uh so everyone
please welcome another round of golf
clapping for ian
thanks jared i'm excited to be here um
so when uh jared asked me to speak i was
uh working for a company called ursa
computing which is a startup company
founded by wes mckinney who i think many
of you know as the creator of the pandas
library for python so the mission at
ursa computing was to accelerate um
applications of apache arrow but since
then wes and the team at ursa have
joined forces with some other pioneers
of the apache arrow ecosystem especially
some folks who are working on sort of
gpu accelerated data science
and we formed a new company called
voltron data and our goal now is to
create a unified foundation for the
future of analytical computing it's
optimized for like diverse hardware so
cpus gpus and beyond
and it's compatible across languages and
fast and efficient and again all based
on apache arrow so i'm excited to be
part of that team we are also hiring so
i'll show you at the end the link to go
to
um but today i will be speaking about
these two r packages that i created
before joining ursa or voltron tidy
query and query parser so these packages
sit at the intersection of sql and r as
do a few other packages that i'll
mention um but also sort of broaden this
topic to speak more generally about what
you might call syntaxes for data
manipulation or you know data interface
languages effectively like the human
interfaces uh to data through code that
we all use
so sql is one of these
in r there are several right there's d
plier there's data table
um if you like to inflict paint on
yourself there's base r of course
and in python there's pandas and other
languages have others so you know tidy
query and query parser are just um one
example of this like broader trend
toward decoupling those interfaces or
front ends from engines or back ends so
i'll describe some history of how we
ended up in this like scientific and
statistical uh computing community with
interfaces that were tightly coupled to
engines in the first place
but then how in the last five years or
so there's been a trend toward loosening
those couplings and then toward the end
of the talk i'll lay out a vision for
kind of where that trend might lead
and i'll describe some work that the
arrow community as well as some of us at
voltron data are doing to realize that
vision
but actually i'd love to start first
with a poll question
and i have a link that i want to share
but suddenly i cannot see the chat
so i'm going to stop sharing for one
second and paste that link and i'll
start sharing again and i believe nicole
is going to
repost this
in the slack so there's a slido link
that should take you to a poll
all right
and i'll start the poll
uh and the question is just do you know
sequel so you know um
since this is an r meetup i'll assume
like almost everyone here knows r and
uses r but i'm curious to know about
familiarity with sql so you know if you
have any experience with sql you know at
least a little bit some familiarity you
can answer yes
so i'll just wait one minute
for folks to answer
but it looks like
um
yeah unless things change dramatically
the vast vast majority almost everyone
uh you know in this crew um knows knows
the sequel and this is consistent with
like what i've seen you know anecdotally
um and what some of the evidence from
things like the stack overflow uh survey
results like uh stack overflow developer
survey results
bears out so
there's one more question
uh which did you learn first sql or r so
at that same link now that should have
changed so there's a second question
being posed
which did you learn first sql rls are so
i'll
give you a minute to answer that
all right
so this is kind of a
split um
pretty evenly uh
a lot of people learned r first um as
you might expect in a crew of you know
statistical computing nerds um but you
know almost half learned sql first so
um i don't know if there's any evidence
on this but anecdotally i've seen it to
be the case that um a lot of people
learned sql before r uh in the broader
community but um you know it seems like
maybe 40 some percent of this crew has
uh but yeah and a nice split there
so
if you know some sequel and you know the
tidy verse and r i mean one of the
things you'll know is that sql and d
plier you know this sort of centerpiece
of the tidy verse although they have a
very different syntax um when you look
at them more abstractly they have a lot
in common uh just one second
my cursor keeps disappearing on me okay
so um
the you know
the tidy so yeah next slide so first of
all both dplyr and sql databases
generally require that you organize data
in a certain way in order to work with
them so the tidy verse has this set of
rules you know for how you have to
organize your data each variable forms a
column
each observation forms a row each value
typically has its own cell and then each
type of observational unit forms like a
table or data frame or tibble
and again in the tidy verse we call that
tidy data and it's how you need to
structure your data in order to work
with it with dplyr but in the world of
sql and databases essentially those same
rules are the essence of normalized
tables in a database
so then once you have your data in this
kind of structure regardless of whether
you call it tidy or third normal form or
whatever generally the types of
operations you would apply to that data
are roughly the same in dplyr
as they are in sql so dplyr of course
provides this set of functions or verbs
with the idea being that you can just
use a few of these verbs to do most of
the kinds of data manipulation that you
would ever need to do
dplyr was created by hadley wickham
as i'm sure you all know and when hadley
created it he more or less brought the
semantics of the sql select statement
to the r language with just a few
changes and of course using you know the
syntax of the r language
um and if you're not familiar with sql
the sql select statement is what you use
to query data in the sql language so
when we say sql query we're typically
talking about the sql select statement
um so
a select statement never modifies data
in place
it retrieves the data and effectively
makes a copy of it and then manipulates
that copy and then returns the results
so um
you know
let's look at the
how sql compares to dplyr so dplyr has
verbs
uh sql the sql select statement has
clauses and there's seven main clauses
in the sql select statement select from
where group by having order by and limit
um and each of these maps on to a
deployer verb although the mapping is
not exactly like a clean one-to-one
mapping so i'll go through this
so first of all the from clause
specifies which data frame or table
you should you know retrieve the data
from
that in sql maps to
just simply
the name of the data frame you know
which you would use like at the top of
your dplyr pipeline
um
moving on the select clause in a select
statement um maps onto like a few
different constructs in d plier
depending on what you're trying to do if
you are just retrieving existing columns
out of a data frame or table well that's
that's just the select verb in d plier
however if you are mutating columns
you're using expressions to define new
columns that's mutate in d plier or
transmute if you prefer
um and then lastly if you are uh
computing aggregates using aggregate
functions you know sum count max stuff
like that uh then you use summarize in d
plier
the where clause which you know filters
rows maps to filter and d plier
group by directly maps to group by
having is um
in sql it does filtering but it does
filtering after the grouping and
aggregation so
uh
dplyr has simplified things and just
reuses the filter verb for this but
after uh group by
um and then order by corresponds to a
range
in d plier and then finally limit
corresponds to head or slice
um
and so that's you know that's roughly
how you map sql onto d plier or you know
the arrows could be going in the other
direction but it's not just d plier that
has modeled itself in this in this way
like on some of the same underlying
abstract ideas as sql um sql has been
like really influential
such that many other systems you know
pandas the spark data frame api
all follow the same semantics but just
to varying degrees um
dplyr and the spark data frame for
instance kind of holistically adopted
this sql abstraction from the start but
others like pandas gradually like
adopted certain elements of it over time
so um incidentally i'm not really going
to talk about um much besides r and um
and and uh and sql in this first part of
the talk but
i if you're interested kind of in
understanding how pandas would map on uh
to this sort of you know mapping right
here i gave a talk
at a local python user group meeting
a couple of years ago one second
um and it is there's a repo oops yeah
there's a repo here
um uh e m cook slash dpplier dash pandas
on github where there's some slides that
kind of explain how you could also map
pandas dataframe functions
to deploy verbs and how you can if you
wish use pandas in a deep plier-ish sort
of a way so take a look at that if
you're kind of under interested to
understand how this this mapping extends
to pandas
um
so
one of the cool things about having this
common abstraction that underlies both
sql and dplyr is that it enables dplyr
code to be translated into a sql select
statement and use to query a database
and as i'm sure many of you know that is
exactly what the db player
package does so with db plier you
connect your database um you refer to a
specific table in the database uh and
then you chain on dplyr verbs much as
the same you will as you would if it was
a table or a data frame that you were
manipulating and db player translates
all of those departure operations into a
sql select statement um sometimes it
does that with the help of a custom
db player back-end package and then it
runs
the resulting sql select statement on
on the database and it uses the dbi
package
in r to do that so
um i have an example of this i will show
you just a moment
all right let me
increase the size of this
yeah so this is i mean if you haven't
seen db plier this is how it works um
you load some data and i'll be using for
a lot of these examples the nyc flights
13
data set
and then you load dplyr
and then what this line does is it
copies the data out of the data frame
the flights data frame that comes with
nyc flights 13 into a database table in
this embedded sqlite database that comes
with um with dbplier but you can also
use like any other database
that's supported by dbplier or various
backend packages for it it's just that
sqlite is kind of the easiest way to do
an example without having some external
database that you're depending upon
so
i'll run that
whoops
i think i already ran it so it told me
the table already exists
and then you run um a deployer command
and you get the result and so um under
the hood what is happening
is that db pliers translating all of
these deployer verbs into a sql query
and one really cool thing about dbplier
is that includes this
function show query
so if you append that onto the end of
your
you know pipeline here you get not the
result set but in fact the sql query
that it runs to generate that result set
so
that's a pretty neat feature of dbplier
okay
so i've been using db player for a few
years and i authored a custom backend
package for it for uh impala a few years
ago
and i've made a few like contributions
to it also but around 2019 i got really
curious about going in the opposite
direction so converting sql to dplyr
so that you could you know say use a sql
statement to query an r data frame so at
the time i was working at cloudera and i
was creating a series of coursera
courses about sql so basically i was
like neck deep in sql for over a year
um and then we launched the courses and
i was like looking for an r side project
to work on so it seemed like a natural
fit
um
and so uh i but i didn't want to
reinvent the wheel right so i looked
around and saw like are there any other
packages that convert sequel to dplyr
and there were there were none i didn't
find anything but there is a very
popular package uh that does something
similar um and it's the sqldf package
created by gabor grotindik so let me
show you if you're not familiar with
that how this works so
um when you have some data loaded in a
data frame in r you can load this sql
sqldf package and then call the main
function in it which has the same name
as the package sqldf
and that function
what it actually does under the hood
is it does not parse your sql statement
or really understand much at all what
the sql statement is asking uh in terms
of data manipulations instead it sets up
a database transparently to the user
sets up a database that's embedded
inside our it's an sqlite database
and then it loads the data from the r
data frame into that into a table in the
sqlite database
and then it runs your sql query on the
database and then returns the result as
an r data frame so
you know that's kind of a neat trick and
it's become an extremely popular package
it's been around for a really long time
and there's like lots of lots of people
who use this um
you know this is something i saw a lot
working as a data science educator is
that a lot of users who come to r
they're really interested in doing a lot
of sort of higher value tasks with r
they're interested in machine learning
the data vis shiny stuff like that
and they're somewhat dismayed to have to
learn a whole new syntax for data
manipulation if they already know sql
just to sort of prep the data for those
uh those higher order you know
applications so those users are often
really you know sort of enamored with
this ability to just run sql queries um
uh you know use sql to manipulate data
in our data frames but there's some some
limitations of sqldf that's it's
important to recognize like i said it
works by copying the data out of r and
then into this database uh this works
pretty well for smaller data it does
introduce some latency especially on the
very first query for a particular data
frame because it has to like copy that
data out
but it's you know it's pretty well
optimized actually um and subsequent
queries are like pretty fast but
if you have a really large data set um
it it starts to slow down a lot and also
just kind of architecturally speaking
like copying data to a different system
um is a bit of an anti-pattern you know
there's the serialization
deserialization cost there's the
potential like
loss when you're converting r data types
to sqlite data types
so not exactly the architecture i was
looking for so i
set out to create something a little
different
and i realized that this problem kind of
broke down into two parts the first part
was parsing the sql query into some kind
of like abstract representation of all
the data manipulation steps in it and
then the second part was actually
applying those data manipulation steps
uh to an r data frame um so
uh
yeah so uh this really turned into two
two two packages not one uh and the
first one named query parser uh is on
cran and github and um i will confess
that like when i first set out to do
this i dramatically underestimated the
the challenge of solving this first
problem uh but i did manage to do it
with some limitations so let me tell you
a bit about more this more about this
package i keep losing my cursor so hold
on one moment
got it back
all right so
um let me actually go to an example
before i tell you how it works so the
main function in query parser is named
parsequery
so what it does is it takes a quoted sql
select statement
as input and then it returns so let me
show you i'll run it
what it returns is a structured list
that sort of
has a structure similar to the structure
of a sql select statement so you can see
this has a sublist named
select
another sublist name from and so forth
group i uh so sub lists that you know um
that are named for the the different
clauses of the sql select uh select
statement and then inside the sub lists
each
sql expression
is translated to an r expression
and if you include this option tidy
verse and set it to true then in
addition to taking advantage of like
base r functions it will use uh tidy
verse functions like functions in d
plier
and
you know a few other of the uh the tidy
verse functions uh tinyverse packages
so
there's also a few attributes such as
whether a given uh whether the query or
a given set of expressions like
aggregates or not so um but what these
what these these uh expressions are
they're unevaluated are expressions so
they're quoted or diffused or
unevaluated are expressions
so
yeah so there's a few things that are
kind of cool about this query parser
package one is that it is implemented
entirely as r code so there's no imports
there's no depends there's no c pulse
plus code there's no like external query
parser it's just r code calling base r
functions
as i said there is this option to emit
tidy verse functions but it doesn't
actually depend on any tidy verse
packages
another thing that's kind of cool about
this
query parser package is that i wrote it
to perform semantic translations not
like literal translations so for
instance one of the things you see
sometimes people do
in sql is they use sum of one to
compute a count of the rows this is
exactly the same thing in sql as count
star
but in in d plier and r if you do sum of
one you will not get that result it will
not like uh accumulate one over all the
rows you'll just get a one out of it uh
it treats one like a scalar
um so what d what uh queen person does
is it translates this
uh semantically into like what your you
know your meaning is which is the number
of rows times whatever scalar you put
inside which is is one in this case
another neat thing about crete parser is
that um it prevents you from from uh
running dangerous functions so you know
i imagined when i was creating this that
someone would eventually like expose the
sql interface through
like a publicly accessible
shiny app
and i didn't want someone's system
getting hosed when a user cleverly
included something like this
in the um sql query that they're posting
so
it actually has a list of all allowed
functions and operators and everything
and uh it checks your sql query against
that list and only allows
functions that you know
only allows queries where all the
functions are on that list
okay so the details of how this works
are kind of complicated and beyond the
scope of this talk but here's just like
a rough sketch
of how how it works um first it splits
the query into all those clauses
then it splits the clauses into strings
that contain each of those kind of
expressions
that exist
then here's where it gets a little like
messy it does a bunch of string
manipulations
to change sql strings into things that
pass as r expressions
um so that the r like expression parser
will recognize them as valid expressions
this is sort of a
deeply unsatisfying and hacky
part of this process um but uh it was
much easier than trying to like model
the entire syntax of the sql expression
language
then um the the r function ster2lang um
is used to parse those expressions into
actual unevaluated r expressions
uh then
sort of the the heart of query parser is
this whole bunch of steps that happen in
the middle where the expression is
unquoted values are substituted in
um and then
it's deparsed and we do some additional
string manipulations and then re-parse
it there's just a whole series of very
complex steps that happen uh it's a bit
of like a rube goldberg machine frankly
um
not enough super elegant design um in
the middle but but it does work
uh and then finally um the resulting
like abstract abstract syntax tree the
unevaluated like r expression is
manipulated a little bit
uh checked for validity and then
returned
as that that object that you saw that
list
that you saw so that's more or less how
it works um it's kind of slow at doing
all this
uh it takes maybe oops takes maybe a
hundred milliseconds or up to like a
couple hundred milliseconds
uh for a more complex query um so this
is really slow like this would be
unacceptable in the world of like high
performance databases but it you know if
you're just running a single query like
it it doesn't add noticeable overhead um
to the time it takes to run uh like a
single dplyr you know query so
it feels feels more or less
instantaneous even though it's rather
inefficient you know
computationally
okay so moving on to the next piece tidy
query um this is the package that as an
end user you probably use
most often it would be pretty rare that
you would want to make direct use of
query parser
so let me go to an example
of tidy query lost my cursor
okay got it
back so the main function in tidy query
is named query so i will load the
package
keep that nyc flights 13 data
um and so you just call the function
query
and you pass do it a sql select
statement so this really works
much the same way i mean as a to the end
user the interface is much the same
as sqldf you just have a function that
you simply pass
a sql select statement to and then it
returns the result as a typical or data
frame to you um
and it does this by well you know let me
go through how it does it in a minute
but um
there are some other ways to use it
though
another thing you can do is kind of use
it as a um well let me let me show this
way if you if you leave the from clause
out
certainly get rid of from planes and
instead put planes at the beginning and
then pipe planes in this works too so
you can take the data and pipe it in and
this allows it to be like used
in a deployer pipeline the only thing is
you need to leave the from clause off
because now where the data comes from is
defined by the first argument
this opens up the possibility of doing
this kind of stuff where you just use
query as if it was in other dplyr verbs
so you can filter
you can arrange but say you just really
don't like summarize for some reason
you don't like group by and summarize
cool just do the do the do that stuff in
sql
and that's that's what happens in this
step
so you can just pipe it on
to other
dplyr verbs
so let me uh explain how this works a
little bit so the first thing that uh
this
query function and tidy query works is
the first thing it does is just simply
call the query parser parse query
function and get that that list
um that i showed you in the previous
step
um and then it
has to do some some some work to
determine like what sequence of d player
verbs to call
um and pass those expressions that are
in that list uh two so then it um
uses dplyr together with arlang
to do a bunch of uh kind of
that similar sort of quasi quotation
unquoting quoting
substitution work
to evaluate all those expressions in the
context of the data frame and then it
returns the result so
uh oops i'll get back to that in a
second so one really cool thing about um
about well so before i get to that let
me just show
that uh there are some limitations of
tidy query in terms of what sql it
supports um but it it supports all these
main
sql
select clauses
and it can take some pretty some pretty
uh complex queries so
um it deals with joins it deals with you
know expressions like is not null in
between that sort of don't map uh
directly to
um any sort of base r syntax
uh and you know so the full complement
of your basic like sql select statement
clauses it works with
i'll talk about the limitations in a
minute so but another really neat thing
is that your data doesn't have to be in
a data frame for this to work it just
has to be in some object that deplier
can can be used on so for instance
hadley a few years back created this dt
plier package which exposes a um
a d plier interface to the data table
uh package so if i load that and i take
um
these two
tables used in this complicated query
here flights and planes and i change
them into
data table
objects through this lazydt function
which is part of dtplier then i can run
the query but it's not running it on a
data frame it's running it on a data
table
and it generates the same result so it's
you know this allows you sort of in a
way that sql df doesn't it allows you to
run on anything that has a deep higher
interface
um and i've i you know concocted some
some uh
circular examples uh that you know
generate a sql query and then parse it
and then generate the d plier and then
parse it to generate the sql query you
know you can use db plier
uh and and tidy query to just generate
like a circular um
a circular process of queries which is
pretty wild but you know it actually
works and generally tidy query will emit
uh
d it will generate dplyr that is like
pretty clean and optimized
so one other cool feature that i want to
show you about
is that if you want to not run the sql
query using the plier but just see what
d plier
it generates there's a function show d
plier that's part of tidy query so you
run that and then instead of
instead of giving you the results
it gives you the dplyer pipeline
uh that it uses to generate the results
so it you know translates the the sql
into this and then just displays that so
sort of the the reverse of show query in
db plier
so you know i like this because it it
enables tidy query to be used not just
as a means of querying a data frame with
sql but also as a means of taking your
existing sql skill and using it to learn
dplyer skill that was part of my
motivation uh for creating this
so some limitations that it's important
to mention
um
currently
query parser and tidy query do not
support sub queries that one is probably
the biggest like um omission right now
that i would love to work on i've been
uh kind of busy lately and haven't had a
chance to do it but certainly if
anyone's interested in collaborating um
please reach out through github or my
email addresses and the slides here
and it would be neat to get some
collaborators to help with this um a few
other things that doesn't support unions
that's pretty straightforward to
implement i just haven't done it yet uh
sql 89 or implicit style join notation
where the joint conditions are in the
where clause
it doesn't support that because sort of
disentangling what is joint conditions
and what is um filter you know filter
expressions is quite difficult it does
it does support the so-called sql 92 or
explicit join notation and that's the
that's the examples that i showed before
you use that
it doesn't support joins of three plus
tables uh when i created it it was
actually impossible to support those
generally because of some
ways that dplyr
joins didn't quite match sequel joins
but hadley has done some rewriting of d
player since then so i think it should
work in theory now
and then a couple of these other sort of
more sophisticated things in sql like um
the with clause or common table
expressions doesn't support that yet but
it in theory could and then window or
analytic functions with the over
um expressions that does not support
that either so um you know if uh if
anyone's interested in contributing to
some of this functionality i'd love to
help you through that process
um or if there's something that's not on
this list of limitations that you see
it's not working properly please report
it love to get bug reports there's lots
of testing
but there's always things i missed so
um love to hear bug reports
okay so now i'm going to kind of
move to the second part of the talk and
i don't have a lot of slides on this uh
so mostly i'm just gonna gonna talk
um but um
you know so as i said at the beginning
this work that i did uh was motivated by
this this idea that
you know it would be cool if we didn't
have each engine tightly coupled to its
interface it would be it'd be cool if we
could use any interface to you know to
drive any engine
um users don't write code for engines
they write code for interfaces um
and if you go like way way back to the
early days of computing with data like
before relational databases the
distinction between engines and
interfaces was mostly moot because each
interface was tightly coupled to an
engine
if you wrote code for a particular
interface you were kind of stuck using
that associated engine
and if the engine no longer met you meet
your needs you were kind of out of luck
the only solution was to you know
rewrite your code to use a different
engine well sql came along sql and
changed this
gradually it didn't happen
instantaneously but over time sql kind
of became you know one interface to rule
them all in the database world
and gradually any database that kind of
wanted to play in the big leagues like
needed to to make sql its interface to
tightly couple itself to sql um and
because sql was like so much more usable
than most of the other data manipulation
interfaces that were available at the
time
this standardization on sql like really
helped to accelerate the rise of data
analytics
and also the abstraction underlying sql
as i discussed earlier
has had a major influence on like a lot
of what's come
since then sql of course is like an ansi
an iso standard it's been revised and
expanded several times um and although
the language today has like fragmented
into a bunch of separate dialects um
which in turn which are actually now
sort of coupled tightly to specific
engines
still sql remains probably the closest
thing we have to a
universal representation of data
manipulation operations today
um but meanwhile so there's some stuff
going on in the database world there but
then as fields like scientific computing
and statistical computing and data
science sprung up
sql and databases didn't gain as much
traction there early on um and there's a
lot of reasons for this i mean i'm not
sure what they all were but i think the
declarative syntax of sql the lack of
sort of standard facilities for
extensibility and program
programmability um those were some
factors kind of the rigid model imposed
by relational database systems um
they were a little odds at odds with the
style of programming and you know
languages like python and r
and some of the other you know
languages that were flourishing uh early
on there
uh i think you know open source pioneers
in the scientific and statistical
computing communities folks like wes uh
when he when he built pandas um and you
know the developers of the original
developers are and then you know hadley
and um matt dowell and folks after that
who built you know other interfaces on
top of of r
um sort of uh
you know
wanted to create like richer uh syntax
more expressive uh more easily
extensible more seamlessly programmable
um more idiomatic for like users of that
language um
and so they sort of you know uh at the
beginning like left databases behind in
many cases and built things uh things
like pandas and dplyr
um
and you know again early on uh
in particular but still today like
pandas is an interface but it has an
engine underneath it and it's tightly
coupled so um dplyr early on
uh was an interface but in the early
days before db player like the only
thing that could do is power the dplyr
engine in r underneath it
um so we were kind of back to this
tightly coupled interfaces and engines
um but then um
uh
you know like there's there's
opportunity there were opportunities
here it was clear um to to decouple as i
said because um the data you know if you
look at like the data manipulation
operations that could be expressed in
pandas syntax or in dplyr syntax uh most
of them could also be expressed in sql
there are some exceptions but at an
abstract level there is a high degree of
overlap between
these
you know these three interfaces and
others and their respective um you know
yeah and their respective engines but um
uh you know another factor i think is
that traditionally databases worked by
ingesting all your data storing it like
in a proprietary closed binary format
and then mediating all access to it
through the sql interface and i think in
the early days especially this really
contradicted the values of openness and
extensibility and all this in the python
and our communities and you know the
broader uh statistical computing and
scientific computing communities python
and r like already had ways of
representing data in memory
and those were different from the
formats that the sql databases used
one notable thing is that
because the in memory format that say
you know that numpy which was sort of
what came before pandas used to
represent arrays
was not the same as the in memory format
that sql databases used to represent
arrays or columns there wasn't really a
basis for sharing code between these
these different
systems either
and then you know so if you wanted to
say
take advantage of a sql database in
order to not have to rewrite all these
same operations
in python or in r well then you need to
deal with this like huge serialization
deserialization cost to move the data to
another place and then to make matters
worse like a lot of databases early on
were row oriented not column oriented so
really had a lot of bad performance on
some of the um sort of columnar type
work that people were interested in
doing in python and r so
i think you know many reasons for this
this this divide another was sort of
this persistent dogma early on that
sql engines run on servers not on pcs so
this is another another factor for sure
although there were early on like you
know
i think projects like uh sqldf like i
mentioned there were early sort of
examples of um creating an interface
that broke through
uh this uh
you know this tight coupling even if the
architecture of it was was maybe not
ideal so this situation of sort of
tightly coupled um interfaces and
engines persisted for some time and it
has some interesting consequences today
like we think of data frames and tables
uh
as different things even though they're
like mostly the same um
another another effect of this is that
like uh there's all this work that's
gone on in the sql and um data warehouse
community to like get really blazing
fast speed uh out of query engines and a
lot of that didn't flow down to r and
python and languages like that because
the communities were just so separate
um again there are some exceptions to
something data table is an example
uh of uh you know on both counts right
they use the word table uh instead of
dataframe and they you know they brought
like really good performance um you know
into into r so there's some exceptions
um but you know around 2016 or so uh we
started to see like more of a
convergence
um in this world so
this brings us to this diagram so
um right you know right around 2016 a
bunch of exciting things started to
happen um the kind of the wall between
databases and data warehouses on one
hand and then scientific and statistical
computing on the other hand started to
crumble a little bit
it started to be easier to interoperate
between python and r and other languages
thanks in part to projects like apache
arrow
that tried to create some standardized
interfaces between them
um
and a bunch of other projects came out
during this time i mean you know the
work i did with tidy query and uh and
query parser was one example of this but
there's many others i mean db player
that i think that started in like
2018 i want to say maybe it was a little
earlier um originally deployer didn't
have a way to query databases but then
it was added as db player well first it
was part of dplyr then broke it on into
db player
it's another example
in
the python world there's a package
called data frame sql that was created
there's a few others there were some
multiple examples of k of attempts to
port d plier or something d plier like
to work in um in python on pandas data
frames uh so people started to be really
interested in um in loosening the
coupling between these things meanwhile
in the sort of data warehouse community
um the apache spark project was really
influential at changing some of this it
helped kind of accelerate like a
convergence of the world of databases
and data warehouses and
python and r and scientific computing
so pi spark spark r later projects like
sparkly r and koalas
koalas is a
pandas-like interface to spark
i think these demonstrated sort of that
there were ways to cross these language
barriers and expose interfaces through
exposed engines through different
interfaces that they weren't sort of
originally designed for
um
the problem with this is uh that
as like all these projects grow and
there's even more sort of dimensions
that i'm not you know portraying on here
like for instance this whole i mean i'm
just sticking to python in our world
here so add in other languages
um add in projects like around gpu
computing and you know non-cpu
uh based engines and you just get this
like massive combinatorial explosion of
new innovations which is exciting but
it's also kind of concerning i mean uh
this diagram you know just rapidly turns
into like a terrible spaghetti bowl um
and you know puts them into question
like the sustainability of some of these
projects uh and something reno really
has to give so um
you know
there's multiple solutions to this
problem i think but one that we're
really interested in pursuing in the
apache arrow community and at voltron
data is this idea of making a general
language agnostic
compute intermediate representation or
compute ir
uh into which every interface could um
every interface you know that was
interested in being compatible with this
could could uh you know write a compute
ir representation and every engine that
was interested in being compatible this
could could consume it um and so you
know for instance d plier could uh
compute could generate compute ir but
then you could run on any engine that
could consume it so you could cross
language barriers you could send it to
different you know cloud computing
vendors um and so forth and so there's
been work that's that's happened here i
mean like there's multiple projects um
where bits of this have been chipped off
like some of the work that's happening
in the apache beam project seems like
some interesting prior art here and
there's others but we in the arrow
community
are thinking a lot about sort of how to
solve this problem in a really truly
language agnostic kind of very standard
way
going forward so
um
yeah so we you know this is actually
going to be the subject of a talk at
uh the new york r conference one second
so um wes mckinney who is the cto of
voltron data um is going to speak on uh
friday september 10th at the new york r
conference and he's going to talk a
little bit about some of the details um
of what we're hoping to achieve with
that you know compute ir and some of the
rest of the sort of vision of apache
arrow um to date and and in the future
and he'll talk a little bit about like
what's what we've been up to at ursa
computing and then now you know having
joined these other teams as voltron data
so i hope i hope you get a chance to see
west talk there
i know jared was going to roast wes as
he always does
but i'm sure wes will have
lots of interesting stuff to say there
as well
so uh lastly i wanted to mention uh
before we take questions that voltron
data is hiring
um and i'll show
some of the jobs we have we
for you know our folks there's a senior
r developer job here that might be
interested in applying to
we're also just opening um we have jobs
across a bunch of roles
one of our goals continues to be to
support the uh increased deployment of
like apache arrow open source solutions
in enterprise and you know corporate
environments and so forth so we're
hiring some support engineers and
support engineering managers
to help with that so definitely check
that out
and thank you and i'll take questions
well thank you very much for talking
i'll give you a little golf clap
personally i hope other people applause
in the crowd as well
uh and yes uh roasting west is a
time-honored tradition at the conference
and it's it's a great show hope everyone
attends in fact last year he gave a
joint talk of neil richardson he thinks
in the crowd and neil's fun fact that he
just comes to see me roast wes
that's just part of it
it's such a good time because west is a
great sport
i love wes that's why i give him a hard
time and yes i've made him give talks in
our t-shirts i put our stickers on his
luggage just because you know why not
um so we do have a question about the
name of the company
um they love the name voltron data but
aren't you just waiting for a lawsuit
um i will refer that question to our
in-house counsel
but uh no i mean uh you know i think the
metaphor of coming together of these
disparate parties coming together
certainly salient here i i can't really
speak to uh you know trademark law but
um
i hope not
captain planet data was taken
all right cool yes i actually actually
texted wes the day i'm like i hope and i
was like for your hex sticker it needs
to be a picture of voltron and wes is
like we want to make sure the trademarks
are available for that first yeah that
would be a way to probably get sued so
yeah yeah that might be pushing it too
far
all right cool um question about so db
player often times will write like
inefficient sql code um how does tidy
query fair go in the other direction is
it is it
efficient d player code or do you know
have you known some issues with the the
quality of it
yeah it's pretty efficient because it's
a it's a simpler problem space going in
the direction of sequel to r um i mean
especially
uh i i haven't tackled some of the real
sources of major inefficiency um like
kind of common table expressions and sub
queries like for instance um you know
a really a really smart sql engine will
do optimizations like you'll recognize
that you have a sub query but you're
using it in such a way that it can
convert it internally to a semi-join
um and it will do things like recognize
that you have two identical subqueries
and then just compute them only once
so i think that as
uh this package grows to include some of
those things that it currently lacks yes
that will probably be more of a problem
the need to optimize right now you know
given that all it's doing is converting
like single select statements it's it's
pretty optimal and it writes like
code that's it's about as efficient as
it could get there's many different
paths that it can take um you look at
the
tidy query code
there's like yeah there's this thing
there's a really quite large number of
different paths it can take to optimize
um you know the number that minimize the
number of different deployer verbs that
are being caused
that are being called um yeah i i know
that db player
um well it's gotten better so early on
like it had very little in the way of
optimization and today it has some sort
of static optimization but nothing like
um you know dynamic uh optimization like
you know a system like apache spark has
just incredible
um you know runtime optimization uh that
we you know the db player can't achieve
but i know you know that that's an
interesting subject that hadley has like
put out some calls for folks in the past
uh to contribute uh if you're interested
to make db player more efficient so um
yeah certainly
i'm sure you know that's still something
uh
that the folks in our studio would love
if folks are interested in contributing
to to make it more efficient i'm sure
yeah so now there's um a colleague of
mine who's like you knew like a
redshift very well and he just couldn't
quite get the db player queries to be as
good as what he wrote
um but again he knows red shirts a lot
better than i did so you know for me the
db is already big heads up
yeah well i mean one of the things i've
seen people do is you know they they
call that uh that show query function
and then they do some manual tweaks yeah
not not really a clean workflow but it
gets you most of the way there
definitely done stuff like that before
too
um and you mentioned about how like a
lot of sql engines
um
automatically optimize the code so would
it be help would you be able to benefit
from calling either sql explain
or maybe copying the parser from
something like postgres would that help
you figure out the optimizations and
then that's built the parsed out
expression you could then deployerize it
after that
oh yeah for sure i mean um as i
mentioned uh this is not this project um
was not an attempt to create something
like an optimal sql query parser uh one
of the reasons that i d i i broke this
into two parts tidy query and query
parser is because most of the
opportunities for optimization um and
efficiency efficiency gains come in the
query parser piece
uh
you know currently query parser is a
pure our query parser that's sort of a
nutty like thing to even try to do
frankly
um the you know
uh there are we could easily make
something that provides exactly the same
functionality as query parser uh but
uses something like apache calcite which
is like a very widely used like uh you
know sort of sql toolkit uh written in
java
um to parse the the sequel and then you
know run optimizations on it and then
emit some kind of you know abstract
representation of it there would be work
though to do to convert that into like
an abstract syntax tree or an
unevaluated r expression that r could
easily understand so i took a shortcut
here um but i i broke them up into two
pieces partly so that if someone was
interested in you know optimizing the
query parsing piece that there was
definitely room to do that so yeah for
sure there's lots of ways uh this could
be this could be made faster
and it's not you just said it and i was
actually just thinking i wanted to ask
you is there an abstract syntax tree for
sql the way there is for r
um
no there's not like
it's dependent on specific database
engines i mean uh yes like each database
engine would have their own
um like ast they would translate the sql
query into but
and and also like you know projects like
apache calcite have given some
opportunity to standardize that so if
you want to create a query engine but
you don't actually want to do the
parsing of the string parsing
uh part of you know of um
dealing with sql uh apache calcite is a
project that can help you there however
like when you're getting down to the
level of like a physical plan that you
know represents like how the query
engine will actually you know perform
the work
uh it's there's no like standardization
from project to project it seems to be
like very you know internally dependent
on like just which sql engine that is um
and that's something we're interested in
understanding with this like compute
intermediate representation project in
the apache arrow project
is like can we standardize some of that
across databases so that if you do want
to say create a high performance engine
um you don't have to solve all those
problems yourself and you don't have to
reinvent the wheel for what is that
abstract representation you should use
to store the logical plan or the
physical plan so
um yeah
okay
um we just had a question this is
something i think a lot of us can relate
to uh this person has trouble filtering
and grouping date values with db player
and i have trouble doing that regular d
player um
does tidy query translate date functions
from sql
um yes some of them um the the piece of
so it would be query parser that would
do this and the piece of query parser
that translates functions is actually
the easiest to understand and contribute
to part of query parser
you do not want to look at the part that
translates like between um you know
between is this like
three operator function um
that does not map cleanly onto anything
in r uh you don't want to look at the
part of cree parser that deals with is
not null expressions uh
because they they're very hard to
translate into something that the r
parser interprets as r could but
the part of query parser that translates
simple functions that take arguments on
the right is very clean and i have
definitely translated a bunch of date
time functions to
lubridate equivalents
so if you keep that
um
in query parser if you said that tidy
verse
equals true argument which tidy query
does uh then it will it will put out
some um
you know uh lubridate functions and
string r functions uh as well uh but
yeah let me know open an issue or if
you're interested in contributing
absolutely open a pr
um if there's ones they're missing
another factor that's a little tricky
though is i'm not targeting like one
specific query dialect here so um you
know for the most part you're not we're
not going to run into collisions uh
between different ones but there are
some cases where like there'll be one
function with one name and like postgres
does something totally different than
say mysql on that function um but
generally i'm trying to sort of target
this like
nexus of like mysql postgres you know
sqlite hive impala drill things like
that
so yeah if you have functions that are
sort of in that general universe uh that
you'd like to see implemented or like to
implement go for it
you mention the if you do tidy versus
equals true you'll translate the some of
the dates that do to lubricate what do
you do if tyrus is false with the date
stuff because base r has some tough date
functions
mostly give up i mean yeah in a few
cases i i try to do something about it
but yeah mostly frankly you give up yeah
lt comes back right
yeah
yeah there's uh there's a lot of just um
non-equivalences where you simply can't
do something without like having to
write like ad hoc code and there's no
ability to like define an inline
function or anything like that here
um so yeah if you look at like inside
query parser um the there's a specific
object that stores all of the
um
the general functions and then there's
another object that stores all the tidy
verse relevant functions it's like
uh it's pretty the tidy versus list is
long so there's a lot that it can't do
without that tiny bursting stuff but
again query parser when he uses it
always always does the tidy verse
translations and i i think it'll be rare
that people use query parser without
tidy queries so is that the default um
title versus true
uh no it's not
but um it is if you use it through query
parser so again most people use it
through query parser when you're calling
that query function you always will get
tidy verse translations yeah okay
and
um
like you've had trouble with between and
i assume like you know there's a deep
player between function i guess the hard
parts identifying between
right the hard part is just dealing with
the the syntax of sql in those cases
where it doesn't um it's not analogous
yeah the the semantics of uh sql between
and deploy between are the same but the
syntax is so radically different um
that you know there's a lot so some of
the work that query parser has to do is
is really quite hellish it's like it has
to
move ahead character by character one
you know one step at a time and then
keep track of like
um are you inside a quoted string or not
how many parentheses uh are in closing
the position we're in right now
um are we in you know well it needs to
know what clause we're in of course but
then it needs to you know it needs to
understand like are we in some sort of
like construct that doesn't use
parentheses and so like is not null
expressions and between expressions and
things like that are just hard because
uh
um you know you have to deal with all
that complexity of like
just translating into something that
makes sense to r yeah
so you said between is tough how about a
case statement
yeah that works too that i should have
mentioned that that was that was
probably the worst one of all yeah but
it works but
quite difficult to implement yeah fair
enough i had a feeling that would be a
tough one
okay
um and there's something that sequel
does but d player doesn't and that's
inequality joints
yes how do you handle that
i have not attempted to to handle
non-echo joins
um
yeah there that's i wouldn't have an
answer to that because i'm sort of by
definition limiting this to
um what d player can do and there's many
examples of this actually um you know
when you look at some of these like sort
of olap style sql queries with things
like
group by with the roll-up in them
uh you very quickly run to things that
d-plugger doesn't support and that like
the deep you know hadley and the other
folks contributing to player have just
said like
unless someone else really wants to like
take this on we're not terribly
interested in uh in adding some of this
stuff uh to d player so
yeah i mean extend d pliers the only
real solution there um otherwise we're
kind of stuck with it yep
i think non-equity joints would be a
huge addition to deep flyer um so a lot
of people and i know like there's
packages i think like emily robinson's
like funnel join has similar
functionality to that and she does
something in the back end to like
compensate for deep flyer not having it
um but i think that that's the only one
i know i think maybe fuzzy joined by by
her brother david also might do
something similar but again it's not in
building a deep pliers all things
compensating for it so it's tough yeah i
mean the thing is that uh
it's it's fairly straightforward to
write like a really naive and efficient
representation of a non-equijoin uh you
know you just do like a
you just do a complete like cross join
and then you just filter the result
uh and that works fine if you're doing
small data but it's completely
impossible if you're dealing with large
data sets because you just you know
multiply them so yeah yeah i get that i
don't get that
there's not a question but for me a
comment i really like the way you pipe
data into query instead of using from
that's pretty cool
yeah that was i thought that would be
kind of a
um
a trick people would like and uh yeah
thanks how does that work when you're
doing like you did in the middle of a
pipeline you just piped right in do you
just leave out the from or do you do
like from placeholder i'm not sure i
caught that yeah you just leave out the
from um
yeah you just totally leave out the from
clause if it's there if you attempt to
pipe in data and you include the from
clause it errors and tells you you can't
do both uh so you leave off the from
clause yeah there's you know one of the
interesting things is that if you look
at um sqldf
uh which i have you know just a ton of
respect for all the work that gabor
gersonde has done in that package it's
got some some neat ideas for uh like
substitutions or like sort of variables
inside the the query string
um where you can like parameterize part
of the string i haven't attempted to do
anything like that either because
i figured that if that's really what you
want you'll just do that sort of outside
um outside the query string rather than
in it um but yeah certainly there's like
opportunities for
lots of of interesting ways to
interesting things like that but yeah
right now it's just leave off the probe
clause
and so it would be like select columns
group by whatever like you just say just
be absent
exactly yeah
some people sort of complain about in
sql uh
if we were writing a sql select
statement in the order that it's
actually processed from wood comp first
yeah um it doesn't but you know uh yeah
so you have to leave it off in the
middle which feels a little strange
yeah and of course that piping and data
from the left doesn't work if you want
to perform a join because then there's
no way to like pass one thing in there
so that only works in the single table
query case still very nifty i really
like that
all right cool i'm going to give
everyone just a moment to see if there's
any like last minute questions sneaking
into the wire here um
in the meantime while we wait and i'll
speak slowly
for people to ask their questions to
drag us out a little bit
um before i even thank ian and i will
certainly do that so i'll reiterate some
of my announcements while we wait for
people if there's any last minute
questions um next month it's uh an r
fold month we're gonna have a meet up
for september 1st or 2nd we're going to
have workshops september 1st we're going
to have the conference september 9th
through 10th
so a lot of things all happening in
early september
then after that we will continue in
october november december in our regular
programming if you have a job you're
looking to fill go to the job postings
channel of the ny hacker slap if you're
looking to get a job go to the job
postings channel of nyrslac this way you
can find a job that someone posted there
i hope everyone
has had a good time and it seems like
i'm looking at both slack and zoom i
think we've had all the questions so
i'll just say i hope everyone's having a
safe end of their summer
and i look forward to the next few
months um again everyone we're
definitely going to be virtual for the
meetup in september and we'll see
about the conference in within the next
week or so we'll have a determination
and subsequent months of the meet up
we'll also you know
we'll go back to
in person as soon as we are able but
until then we'll continue virtual
and with that i don't see any questions
so
a big thank you to ian for talking about
this package i've been actually working
up a client they've been using sql df
and it's causing memory issues because
you are piping it i'm like let's switch
you over to tidy query let's do it let's
do it let's do it
and i've been a big fan of this package
for a few years now so i'm i'm
personally super excited ian came and
gave this talk it was really really
interesting i really enjoyed it i hope
everyone else did so big round of golf
clap and a big thank you to ian for
doing this for us
thanks jared
everyone else have a good night and i
will see you virtually probably or in
person at some point over the next few
times and we'll do all our announcements
coming up very soon thank you everybody
i see there's a bunch of thank yous for
you ian in the in the chat already so i
think a lot of people really enjoyed
your top chat as much as i did
cool yeah my pleasure thanks for
inviting me
absolutely our pleasure to have you
bye everybody